foreign
[Music]
I told you
I'm on vacation well I'm on vacation
I'ma just float come here Mr Parker
Marcus and Emily Parker you have failed
to notify your airline that you are
registered sex offenders
[Laughter]
what the hell is wrong with you
look at us all together again we just
wanted to give you guys a real honeymoon
just found this crawling under our table
he's crawling
it's a prodigy it's amazing
okay do a letting us in a place that's
nice how the hell did you get us in here
you didn't tell him they gonna be long
gone by the time I get into my birthday
you must be Mr Parker apologies for the
change in schedule Mr Young is invited
you for drinks all of you gas I need you
to be really cool and you do that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been cool
released from San Quentin
I got you the best wedding present
why does this coconut taste Cokey
because it's your mom it's really kind
of beautiful if you think about it no
listen to her picture things going at
all it's cool Marcus is cool we're
floating right
let me down get your hands off my wife
ever since he showed up he turned this
relaxing family vacation to total chaos
who does that
through him
why don't we just go back I knew it
chicken it's only one thing left to do
sir
I've never seen that much water come up
a person before did I throw up a lot
your butthole threw up bud
[Music]